e das er von mafkuchen ach sag
bloß hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es
einen Maulwurfkuchen aber auf die etwas
andere Art ich habe nämlich einen
Spekulatius Maulwurfkuchen gemacht mit
Kirschen und einer leckeren Füllung also
gönnt euch auf jeden Fall dieses Rezept
und wir legen jetzt direkt los mit dem
Boden für diese geniale Torte so wir
starten jetzt mit dem Teig für unseren
Maulwurfkuchen dafür brauchen wir
zimmerwarme Butter am besten so ein zwe
Stunden vorher aus dem Kühlschrank
nehmen ich benutze jetzt hier meine
Küchenmaschine die schlägt das nämlich
alles immer super schön fluffig auf wenn
jetzt gerade keine da habt ist es auch
kein Problem einfach euer handrögerät
verwenden so da kommt jetzt Zucker rein
und jetzt habe ich einen kleinen Tipp
für euch ich nehme jetzt nicht nur
weißen Zucker den man so kennt sondern
hier auch Vollrohrzucker den bekommt ihr
auch bei Kaufland und schaut mal das hat
so eine richtig also die Konsistenz die
kenne ich eigentlich nur so aus
amerikanischen Rezepten aus Amerika aber
ich habe das für mich neu entdeckt es
hat so eine richtige karamellig maizige
note also schmeckt richtig lecker und
noch mal viel intensiver wenn ihr den
jetzt gerade nicht da habt und direkt
loslegen wollt mit dem backen könnt ihr
den auch durch weißen Zucker noch mal
ersetzen die Menge aber vertraut mir
probiert es mal aus so Vanille extra
kommt noch mit dazu und was ich jetzt
auch noch mit dazu gebe ist speculatius
Gewürz und dann das ganze so 2 3 Minuten
lang richtig schön cremig
[Musik]
mixen
so jetzt habe ich nacheinander noch die
Eier hinzugerührt und es ist eigentlich
mal besser wenn die Eier jetzt auch
Zimmertemperatur haben damit es sich
besser miteinander vermengt und jetzt
kommen die trockenen Zutaten hinein die
müsst ihr jetzt nicht zwingend sieben
aber gerade bei Backkakao der ist ja
stark entölt das ist dieser hier das ist
jetzt nicht der trinkkakao gerade der
hat ja oder neigt ja immer so zu Klumpen
und daher Siebe ich das Siebe ich aber
auch direkt das Mehl mit durch und auch
back Opala und auch back Pulver und das
könnt ihr dann eigentlich schon
abwechselnd mit Buttermilch mit
einrühren ihr könntet auch Milch nehmen
aber ich finde mit Buttermilch gibt's
auch noch mal so ein besonderen
Geschmack und dann ist der Teig auch
schon
[Musik]
fertig
[Applaus]
der Boden war jetzt im vorgeheizten
Backofen bei 180° Ober und Unterhitze
für 20 Minuten ich habe ihn jetzt aber
schon mal zur Seite gestellt damit der
auskühlen kann und wir machen in der
Zwischenzeit die Füllung dafür habe ich
die sauerkeh schon einmal gut abtropfen
lassen und dann auch noch mal
nachträglich mit etwas das Küchenpapier
noch zusätzlich getrocknet weil da
sollte jetzt echt keine Flüssigkeit mehr
dran bleiben und jetzt nehmen wir uns
ganz kalte Schlagsahne ganz frisch aus
dem Kühlschrank einmal hier in die
Schüssel das ist jetzt nicht viel Sahne
daher benutze ich jetzt auch gar nicht
die Küchenmaschine und jetzt schlagen
wir die Sahne steif allerdings nicht
ganz sondern so dass ihr denkt 10
Sekunden könnte ich sie jetzt noch
schlagen damit sie ganz steif ist weil
dann noch die nächsten Zutaten dazu
kommen und währenddessen lasst ihr eine
Packung Sahne fest einrieseln und die
ganz genau mengangaben stehen natürlich
wie immer hier unten in der
Infobox
[Musik]
so ihr habt ja gesehen dass die
Sahnemasse noch nicht ganz steif ist
also sie fällt vom Löffel ab quasi und
jetzt kommt Puderzucker rein für die
Süße und Vanilleextrakt für den
Geschmack und auch Magerquark gebe ich
jetzt auch komplett mit dazu das ganze
dann nur noch so 10 12 15 Sekunden
komplett steif schlagen und anschließend
kommen dann unsere Kirschen mit dazu die
werde ich aber Vierteln ich mag sie
nämlich wenn sie so richtig schön klein
sind
[Musik]
so jetzt ist die Creme fertig der Boden
ist abgekühlt und hier habe ich auch
noch mal ein Tipp für euch wenn ihr
nicht möchtet dass die Oberfläche
austrocknet generell bei Böden dann
könnt ihr immer ein Küchentuch einfach
feuch machen ausringen und dann oben
drüber legen so das nehme ich jetzt
einmal runter ah der Boden ich finde der
sieht richtig hübsch aus ich wollte den
extra nicht so dunkel deswegen habe ich
nicht so viel Backkakao mit reingenommen
und man soll ja auch merken okay es ist
ein Maulwurfkuchen aber irgendwie einer
der anderen Art jetzt einmal die Ränder
schön lösen dann nehm ich mal gerne die
standardpalette verlinke euch übrigens
auch alle Produkte unten in die Infobox
wenn ihr Fragen zum Rezept habt schreibt
mir einfach ein Kommentar ich lese sie
immer durch so und jetzt machen wir
folgendes ich habe mir schon mal so eine
schöne Tortenplatte geholt weil ich Serv
das jetzt direkt da drauf da habe ich
mir jetzt gedacht rot passend zu den
Kirschen dann einmal Backpapier unten
lösen und dann Höhlen wir einfach nur
ein bisschen was aus und da müsst ihr
aufpassen dass ihr nicht zu viel aushült
sonst habt ihr nur ein ganz dünnen Boden
und dann ärgert ihr
[Musik]
euch
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus wie gesagt
Vorsicht vorsicht dass ihr euch nicht zu
viel wegnehmt denn das wird hier locker
reichen um das gleich noch mal zu
umhüllen und ihr wollt ja nicht dass der
Boden richtig dünn ist später vor allem
also erstmal muss ich betonen das hört
man jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder nicht
aber es ist so es es hört sich schon so
saftig an es fühlt sich saftig an und es
riecht auch richtig gut hier gerade und
jetzt kommt die Füllung einfach oben
drüber die ist jetzt noch noch ein
bisschen weiß die wird nach der Kühlzeit
auf jeden Fall fester daher Kühlzeit
bitte einhalten oh W haben wir denn hier
ein
Grinch lecker ne ja haben woll die mehr
gleich kriegst du mehr und dann kannst
du mit mir Test machen ja Leute das wird
lecker aus und es schmeckt auch lecker
zum die Creme jetzt danke schön für
deine Einung Brot spekulatot das ist ein
ein richtig saftiger saftiger spekulat
Boden ich freue mich ich freue mich auch
auf die sped ne viel Spaß ja also hart
okay viel Spaß danke ruf ich dich gleich
ne ja tut mir leid das wariss na alles
gut war so euporisch alles gut ich werd
es überleben so das werde ich jetzt so
ein bisschen noch mal ja hügelig
verstreichen und dann kommen wie gesagt
ah was ich euch sagen wollte bevor ihr
gleich eure krümelreste mit dazug gebt
da könnt ihr noch einen kleinen Trick
anwenden und zwar einfach noch mal
spekulauskekse so mit den Händen klein
bröseln und mit reinun weil dann habt
ihr noch mal so ein richtig leckeren
[Musik]
Crunch
ich habe hier eine Komposition aus
speekulatius Gewürz Kirschen und Sahne
und Quark du hast glaub ich nicht so
lange im külschank gelassen ne true
merkt man sch das nicht schlimm wir
waren sehr ungeduldig aber wenn man im
Kühlschrank lässt dann steht der Wien 1
wi ein das volkuchen ach sag
bloßor ja dann habe ich mein Ziel
erreicht dass ich das spekul cool habe
ich noch nie gesehen Hal mal die
Winteredition das mal so so IDE kommen
ne der Gedanke kam sehr spontan der kam
sehr spontan gestern Abend bei im
während der Autofahrt nach Hause kam mir
die Idee heute auch so spekulat und
Kirchen also heiße Kirchen und creme
passmer irgendwie ne oh ja der schmeckt
sehr gut oh richtig da kommt mir richtig
so ich will mich jetzt einkuscheln ins
Bett Netflix anmachen und diesen Kuchen
essen bisschen Jurt raus kann das sein
das ist halt Quark Quark und Sahne se
frisch ne es schmeckt auch gar nicht so
süß gar nicht also ich glaube dass auch
so Leute die generell nicht so ein süßes
gewohnt sind dass die das total feiern
würden aber es hat einfach die perfekte
süße finde ich und die Kirschen die
ballern richtig gut gerade also was mir
aufgefallen ist die sind no spekulat KEG
das heißt bisschen Crunch dabei ne ja
gerade bei meinem bis vorhin habe ich
auch diesen diesen Crunch von den K dai
gehab ich sag das wirklich sehr oft in
Videos wirklich sehr oft ne aber ich
habe das Gefühl sogar dass du letz immer
mehr die süße reduzierst aber ich fin's
gut ich mE ich auch langsam
älter also hier fällt mir besonders auf
dass die süße komplett perfekt
ausgeglichen ist weil die ich meine die
Creme dadurch dass die halt Quark
enthält ist die nicht ganz so süß hat
aber ein bisschen Puderzucker dann
kommen noch die Kirschen die
neutralisieren ja auch der Teig ist
angenehm süß also ich feier das komplett
ich will auch nichts daran verändern
leute das ist so ein richtig also man
könnte denken das ein richtig lange so
ein traditioneller klassischer Kuchen
aber der ist eigentlich komett neu so
sieht aus mal das müssen wir mal
einführen hier Winter jetzt hier Spekula
mal Kuchen ne schön zu om mitbringen neü
K mitbringen zum Sonntag das passt doch
ganz gut passt doch wunderbar ja ich
würde mal sagen was machen wir wir
verabschieden uns jetzt oder wir essen
wir essen und verabschieden uns und
essen und essen also bis zum nächsten
Mal Ciao ich hab mit voll Mund
gesprochen das macht man eigentlich
nicht
[Musik]
tschüss